- High School Musical:
The Musical: The Series,
best title ever.
I think it just describes how the show is.
It's very tongue in cheek,
fun,
- Yeah.
- but I play Zack Roy,
who is the rival school theater teacher
and you know, Ms. Jenn and I
used to date in high school,
so this was a bit of, you know,
- Yeah.
- it's like,
do we hate each other?
Do we love each other?
This kind of cat and mouse.
- Oh, I love
that kind of thing.
- Yeah, so--
- That's called tension.
- It is.
- Yeah.
- It's electric.
- But it's fun, man, I'm
not gonna lie though,
I, just even watching that
clip, I can't watch myself.
- I'm the same way, I
don't like watching myself.
- Yeah, it's, there's certain
things I don't mind watching,
like I like certain dance performances,
I'll be like, I'll watch it,
I'm like, you know what?
- Yeah.
- Good job.
That was all right.
But for the most part 90% of the time,
- Yeah.
- I don't watch myself.
- Just let it go.
- Let the art go.
Yeah.
You know, what's funny.
I don't watch me when I'm doing my songs,
but I do watch Kellyokes
because it's covers.
- Yeah.
- So there's something
different about that.
I don't know,
- Yeah.
- I a detach somehow.
- I don't know.
- Yeah.
But I'm.
- It's weird, yeah.
So I, you saw me,
- Yeah.
- I crawled behind the crowd
while we were watching that.
- I am with you.
I can't look at the screen.
I feel so uncomfortable,
but I think that's kind of cool
'cause then you don't change yourself.
I think if you watch, people
watch themselves too much
you change yourself 'cause you
feel like you find the things
that you don't like about yourself,
but that might be what
other people love about you
- Yeah.
- that you don't, yeah.
Anyway, you do you.